welcome to this video playing the guitar
from Belgium this is international
master Stefan docks let's see probably
had been only yeah with g6 early g6 I
think that some age for business is
interesting with okay he's transposing
to a normal line what black also has 97
of course at some point and then I think
h4 is and has a decent idea okay now we
just have normal Benoni
blackest ride for quick counter play on
the queenside I'm just trying to be
quick here let's see maybe just full
centralization now and then go from
there okay black is attacking my e4 pawn
a couple of times should I maybe yeah I
always like the bishop here on age six
I wonder Queen a for Queen h4 is also
something that I'd like to do okay maybe
you just switch the Queen over to the
King side
there are other ideas of course but I
always like to to go for the kingside
position here Bishop h6 maybe here first
yeah why not Bishop h6 Knight g5 might
be might be an idea yeah yeah that's
interesting I probably am had it's not
really interesting I was thinking that
that maybe can play 94 but this 93 Sun I
have to take that yeah and now I thought
Bishop f6 actually but this is not
really good yeah because of rook age 5
but I can go f4 and Bishop f6 writer I
move like Queen b6 I'm I can move the
King yeah I mean I definitely should try
to trade this Bishop Ellis cannot be a
bad idea
okay he's threatening a huge discovered
check 93 especially but yeah okay it's
hard to do without the move anyway maybe
I could have taken first on 1g 724 looks
really medium let's go back here okay
it's trying to trade Queens which I
certainly understand but if I'd trade
Queens now is this this bad for me or
anything I don't know I mean I have a
pretty good control over the center hmm
I can I can also just go to g3 yeah I
think I should keep Queens on it's not
totally clear maybe
so I'd like to go at five-year 85 I mean
yeah it does not seem to be possible at
the moment the 94 it's not really really
on
how can I get any five here maybe double
double on the ephah look III rookie 1e5
this is also stabilizing the queenside a
bit fancy three and so on
interesting
yeah I don't really see a way forward I
have everything on this my ocam is
really a move that he does not mind to
play
g5
yeah that's it's Canadian so I can take
f4 uh yes yeah take care form didn't
didn't think about it maybe it's not a
problem ready but it wasn't planned
no look a three-time wedding queen edge
force on this is isn't this interesting
still rookie form look you from Queen a
fire that looks terrible really hard to
believe that this is possible for black
but Queen f5 seems to hold and believer
I really have no discovered discovered
move rookie - I can - I can do but he
asked Weiner fall back at least I have
that I don't see a way forward I can go
green before Jeff sometimes I really
hate this game okay then I'm taking
there
and what are you doing now
huh still all of a sudden looks good for
wider isn't it doesn't it I mean huh
what is he playing now
huh I see no move really are threatened
okey fire and like looks totally
overloaded Queen f4 maybe or something
like that
Queen a voice possible yeah I only have
seconds so I just have to play
unbelievable stuff here yeah you can't
just take with the hook you can just say
I can also take with the Queen what
server there's really nothing white
worth it on time what kind of game is
that I mean he plays g5 yeah and I go
here and overlook we never fall and then
all of a sudden I mean he's getting into
this trouble and it isn't winning for
white is really really weird check this
check went here there and took here and
Queen f4 is really saving the day that's
the only move that's not losing but it's
really not it's really okay I have to
play Queen takes the edge yeah
I only spotted Queen F form and and then
I had to play move I have only 29
seconds what a weird game it was a bit
strange I mean I mean I really don't
think that this is this is really good
for black e I'm getting this traded and
so on but it's so difficult to find a
way forward
why does certainly okay but you don't
get an e5 and it's not so easy this is
probably okay but okay this I really
didn't have an idea here and I was
shuffling a little bit not sure how to
get to get something going I mean what
should be okay because this is simply
really bad piss on on on on besson but
maybe there's really nothing going on
maybe it's equal yeah okay I just
overlooked Queen take that for hands is
really really bad if I go rook F oneness
maybe not so no much going on yeah okay
not a great game thanks for watching